let's see if we can compute what 14
minus 2 is and then figure out what 14
minus 4 is and then figure out what 14
minus 6 is and I encourage you to pause
this video and try to figure these out
before I work through them so I'm
assuming you've given it a try now let's
think about it the number 14 just by how
it's written we know that it's going to
be one group of 10 that's what this one
tells us plus another 4 ones so let's
verify that we have 14 objects down here
this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 so we
definitely have a group of 10 and we
have one group of 10 here so that's my
group of 10 so let me box that off so I
have my group of 10 and then how many
ones do I have I have 1 2 3 4 I have for
once so this is indeed this is indeed 14
this one that we have right over here
this represents this 10 it's one group
of 10 this is one group of 10 let me
write that down
group of 10 and then we have 4 ones for
4 we I guess we could say 4 4 ones like
that so that is indeed 14 now let's look
at each of these what is 14 minus 2
going to be well we could take away 2 so
take away 1 take away 2 and how many are
we left with
well we still have our one group of 10
so it's going to be 1 followed by how
many ones do we have left over well we
have two ones we have two ones left over
one two so we are going to be left with
twelve
now what about 14 minus 4 so let me let
me clear this out let me clear let me
clear actually let me do it like this so
if I clear that so what is 14 minus 4
going to be so now I'm going to take
away one
two three and four I've essentially
taken away all four ones so what am I
left with
well I still have my one group of ten I
still have my one group of ten and I
have zero ones left over I have no ones
anymore so now I have zero ones and so
14 minus four is ten and that makes
sense
14 is ten plus four and now we're
subtracting four to get 10 let me write
this down this is the same thing 14 is
10 plus 4 10 plus 4 this is 14 and then
we're going to subtract 4 then we're
subtracting 4 so if you have 10 plus 4
minus 4 well the 4 minus 4 is going to
be 0 you're going to be left with 10
plus 0 or just 10 we can do the same
thing up here this is equal to 14 is 10
plus 4 10 plus 4 and then we subtracted
2 and then we subtracted 2 so we're
going to be left with this 10 plus
what's 4 minus 2 it's 2 so that's what
we got right over here let me make this
very clear this simplifies to 2 this 2
right over here this simplifies to 0
this 0 right over here now let's do the
last one
what is 14 minus 6 well we're going to
take away 1 2 3 4 and then 5 and 6 so
now we've broken into our group of 10 so
this is going to be a one digit number
and we are left with 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so
this is going to be equal to this is
going to be equal to 8 and we're all
done